uh okay cool let's get started so guys
um
today we're going to talk about
um implicit regularization of the noise
so and
the plan today is that
um
because this is a pretty challenging
topic and and I think the
the research Community is still in some
sense doing research on this
um so we have some results
um it's pretty complicated so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to somewhat um uh
using a relatively heuristic approach
so I'm going to try to convey the main
idea without doing the actual
uh rigorous statement so so in this
lecture I don't even think I have a
formal statement to State because it's
just a little bit too complicated and
unnecessary right so if I really
approved of the formal version of the
ethereum they'll probably take two
lectures or three lectures
so that's why instead I'm trying to kind
of at least convey the main intuition
why the noise is useful with some still
with some math because without the mask
you don't even see the intuition
sometimes so but but the knife wouldn't
be always rigorous and I want to know
where it is kind of like a not rigorous
and also some part
cannot be made rigorous without
additional assumption and that would be
I will clarifying that as well some part
is really just like for convenience I
ignore some kind of like the dragons but
they can be fixed by just a little more
careful mess and some part is actually
fundamental challenges and you have to
really use additional assumptions or
maybe even change the problem setting to
go through those steps uh regressive
so
um so I guess um the the main portion of
the the talk the lecture is actually not
about any particular loss function it's
about generic loss function we're going
to make some special uh simplification
for them but but you only even need to
really think about parametrization uh in
most of this lecture so so the setup is
that we have a loss function
that's for for this function G Theta and
I'm also going to use x as the variable
as certain cases so and the the the
stochastic descent algorithm by noise I
really mean the noise in ICD
the stochastic algorithm will analyze is
something like this
so Theta T is equal to 30 plus 1 is
equal to T minus Some Noise ingredient
so we have the
full gradient plus some stochastic noise
so where
the expectation of this quasi T is zero
so this is really a mean zero noise but
a distribution
the city you know in the most General
case
in most General case
the distribute distribution of the city
can depend on sterility
right so the noise is distribution
depends on which point you are
evaluating right right so you can see
this formulation at least so far at a
very general level does capture for
example stochastic as you usually know
like the mini batch sarcastic will be
set because suppose you take a mini
batch gradient with a few samples then
is indeed can be written as something
like the full gradient plus a stochastic
variable which has means zero
but we are not going to analyze that
particular version because then the
noise it becomes too complicated in some
sense right so we're going to analyze
much simpler noise in most of the cases
like something like a gaussian noise
so this is a so so strictly speaking
this is more about noisy gradient
descent than stochastic mini batch stock
has definitely designed but they do
share you know a lot of similarities
okay so and what do I try to do is we're
going to gradually build up our
intuition about how does this noise
affect our optimization algorithm so so
we're going to start with you know a
virus like we're gonna have several
levels warm-up so the first Walmart is
that what if you have a quadratic loss
function
so contrasting loss pretty much means
that you have a linear model under the
hood but here I don't even have model
parametization I only have a loss
function so you Theta I say we have a
quadratic loss function and have
gaussian noise
and and also we have 1D
one dimensional functions
like Theta is one dimensional so I guess
here I'm going to use
from now on I'm going to use x as my
variable just to make it more consistent
with the optimization literature and GIS
let's just assume it's one over two
times x squared and this one over two
doesn't really matter it just makes the
gradient cleaner
so
um so then what's the update rule for
this case right you are optimizing a
quadratic function basically
which where the global minimum is at
zero
but you are using stochastic when you
decide or green design with noise
so x t plus 1 is equals to x t
minus ETA
within G of x t plus some noise let's
say the noise has some
scale Sigma
is not doesn't have a skill
so have it means zero on standard
deviation one so basically a noise has
standard deviation Sigma
and gaussian distribution
and now let's compute the gradient the
gradient is really just a x t right the
green of one over two times x square is
the X so plus Sigma Times Square c g
so this is one over ETA x t minus ETA
times Sigma times the CT
this one is not working
maybe it doesn't matter
so
um
so so what's happening here is really
that
this is a construction
meaning that if you have x t then you it
contracts
um a minimum or make the XD smaller by
effective one minus ETA
and this is the stochastic term
that may make actually bigger or smaller
depending on you know when you are lucky
or not right so so in sometimes what
happens is that
so the interesting thing is that if
um
so when
x t is large
um the contraction
is not dominating the construction of
the shrinking is dominating right
because for example suppose your XT is
here
then what happens is that you first
contract it
to somewhere here
right but multiplying one minus ETA and
then you add some stochastic noise so
then maybe at the end of that you may
end up somewhere near
uh the strict ones right so but still
largely speaking you are moving towards
zero because of the the construction or
the shrinking right just because the
shrinking is doing the most of the work
however some so let me finish so the
construction
dominance
however when actually is small
or maybe XC is very small or maybe XC is
zero for Simplicity then the noise
uh is is dominating the process
all right guys this suppose you are
start you start somewhere very very
close to zero
then when you stroke it it doesn't
really change much right because one
minute times the small one number is
still a small number
and name and the noise and noise
probably make it somewhere either on the
left hand side on the right hand side
so so the noise becomes the dominating
part when XC is small
so and eventually basically you are
gonna basically
converts to this uh second case to some
extent
so because you know if the if XP is
larger than you are moving towards zero
and what happens is the eventually
actually becomes somewhat small and
noise is kind of like governing all the
process
So eventually you are just bouncing
you're bouncing just around
Global mean
on a certain level right so you cannot
bounce you cannot bounce around on some
very very high level values because then
your construction is too large you
wouldn't be able to bounce around that
level very much So eventually we will be
bouncing around on certain level
depending on the noise level
right so
um it's kind of like what happens if you
have
I guess um if you think about you drop a
ball you know
kind of a concave kind of thing without
any friction it's not exactly the same
because there you don't have really
um additive noise but you still see this
bouncing around eventually just because
you can overshoot a little bit
um yeah maybe that's not exactly the
right analogy but anyway So eventually
you'll bounce around some the the the
valley uh on a certain level and how do
we kind of process it by the way this
sounds like nothing really to do with
implicit regularization because
eventually whatever you do you always
stay close to the global minimum because
there's no even two other there is no
too low minimum right but the intuition
is very useful for for future since when
you kind of move away from this so this
is indeed important so and let's try to
be more precise
yeah
and this is actually a case that we can
be precise
so
I can solve the recurrence
so we'll solve the occurrence what
happens is the x t is equal to 1 minus
equal x t
X Plus Y is equal to 1 minus Theta x t
minus E so Sigma c t
and then you plug in the definition of x
t again okay y minus ETA one minus Theta
2 minus 1 minus E to the sigma plus C T
minus one
minus ether signocity
and if you realize this you get 1 minus
ETA Square x 3 minus 1. minus 1 minus
ETA times ETA Sigma C T minus 1 minus
ETA Sigma the CT and if you do this for
another level you get one minus Theta
Cube x t
minus 2 minus 1 minus E plus square e to
Sigma
because City
minus 2
and if you do this you know more and
more eventually what you're going to get
is the one minus Ethan to the power of t
plus 1 times x zero
minus E times Sigma times this summation
summation looks like this
is a company linear combination of
constitution
but uh coefficient in front of it is
some power of one minus E times
so
so from this you can see that you know
so actually there are several interest
things about this formula which can give
you some intuition
um so so one thing is that this
thing is is a very strong construction
right so you are this is the the
construction part
right because and in some sense this
term comes from you contract the initial
value by a lot of one minutes ETA so
that basically this becomes negligible
this becomes
negligible
uh when
uh
he it attempts T is much much bigger
than one because you know one month's
equal to the poverty is something like e
to the minus E 30 and with even times T
is much bigger than one then um and this
term becomes you know Superstar
so and you can also see from the other
term
this is the in some sense
you can view this as accumulation
accumulation
of the noise
the noise are not just the hiding up the
noise are accumulated in a certain way
and maybe it's easier even to look at
this
so the lot the noise that you either
lost I lost that is scaled by ETA times
Sigma
so but the noise that you added
second but last one step is scaled by
one minus eight you have additional
Factor one minus E
and how does this one manager come from
this is come from the construction
of the second last step so basically
is what you added in the second last
step
and then because you do another grid
instead we instead of going in the third
step on top of that you still contract
that noise a little bit
right so so or maybe you can see this
from here as well right so this is what
you got from here
but this one is ether comes from the
construction in the very last step and
the same thing happens right so so this
comes from the construction the last two
steps
so basically every time you add noise in
some intermediates that eventually this
noise will die eventually at some point
if you run for long and long enough time
just because there is always a
contraption that is applied after this
noisy step
right so so that's why that was in
multiplied in front of the noise is a
geometric series but it depends on when
you added this noise the the the
coefficient in front of the noise you
know can become smaller and smaller
right so that you you forget about the
very very long history right so if you
add a noise at the very very first step
it doesn't really matter because you
multiply that so when K is equals to for
example T minus one when that's the
noise for C1 then you add it in the
virus First Step then that noise becomes
much or less because you multiply one
minus e to the power K in front of Base
because of the contraction then it
always becomes less and less important
so that's one thing like the
accumulation you know of the noise is
is kind of like a prefers the closed
history and ignore the long-term history
so and another thing is that this is a
sum of gaussian
right because each of this term is your
gaussian and our assumption can see is a
gaussian and because see time something
is still gone
and you can also compute the variance of
this the variance of this
is equals to
Eta Square Sigma squared times the
variance of each of the term which is
something like
one minus ETA to the power 2 okay
so and the point is that if you take T
to go to Infinity then you can know
what's the limiting virus what's the
virus at the end
so if K goes to u p goes to Infinity
you can complete the variance of x t
is roughly something like because
Square Sigma Square
if you you press T to be Infinity one
over two equal to 2K and this is ETA
Square Sigma squared 1 minus one
okay
sorry my writing is not perfect
one minus ETA Square
is how you computer geometric series and
this is ETA Square over Sigma Square
2 ETA minus ETA square but this term can
be dropped because that's going to apply
all the term so this is approximately
just a
on the order of
ETA Sigma Square
okay so in other words
um
like the XC eventually as T goes to
Infinity
eventually has this gaussian
distribution which means zero an
environment something on the order of e
times Sigma Square
so
so I think
so here so far again we haven't really
talked about induct like implicit bias
yet but I think we still already got
some intuition
about what's happening here with the
convex case
so smaller rate
small ETA
means that
um your each of it will have small
bouncing around right so small
stochasticity of the final iterate
because your virus in iterate x t is
smaller
and you have small noise the same thing
also it implies the same thing
and
um
and
um and so basically what happens here is
that in the noise
only makes it harder
to converge
me
so in some sense if you only care about
the quality of the final solution you
converge to the noise is always hurting
you
especially if you're willing to take T
to Infinity right just because so here
you can see that when she goes to
Infinity you still never converts to
exactly the global meat market so you
always have some virus around the global
mean so and you want the virus to be as
small as possible because you want to be
as close to the globe mean as possible
so and the noise is only a hurdle
instead of typing anything
so so this is why
um
um in the classical convex case
so so this is why in the classical
Converses
opposition
typically when you think about noise
it is only about two things it's only
about a the noisy green descent
uh
like a leads to ice less accurate
less accurate
Solutions
so this is a bad thing that's what we
discussed
and second
um
noisy when you said it's faster to
compute
foreign
and the only thing is that you are
trading off this tool
two factors above
that's the kind of the I would say the
typical way of thinking about stop
casting these sense when you really
think about the convex case right so
noise is bad because it hurts your final
accuracy but you want to allow some
noise in certain cases because you
compute faster right so if you think you
can actually don't mean trade off this
in the right way you can get the fastest
algorithm eventually and you can kind of
imagine how you trade off this right so
at the beginning of the optimization you
don't care that much about accuracy you
don't care about that much about
converting to exactly the global mean
you want to go to the Google mean as
fast as possible so that's why at the
beginning you don't care that much about
noise so that's why in the beginning use
an option rate and then when you're
already closed where your goal changes
right because now your goal is really
literally go to the global mean period
so then you can't allow any loans so
that's why you have to Decay your
learning rate so that's why there's
always this kind of depending on your
version of algorithms
so
um so so far this is about uh
[Applause]
um
yeah and also another thing is that just
a side remark which is useful for us you
know which is used for comparison for us
later so for any fixed
suppose you're fixed
heat and sigma
right so the expectation of x t
is always going to zero conversion to
zero as T goes to Infinity right so even
though there's a stochasticity there's a
bouncing wrong your average is always at
zero so this is saying that there's no
bias introduced
by the stochasticity
you only introduced
in some sense some fluctuation of course
fluctuation is also biased but at least
even you can use any bios a systematic
bias against any other directions
so
um
so that's another strategy remark which
will kind of like
compare with you know that and also not
another small remark is that this is
also called
this process
actually has a name it's called Orson
uh open and back process
if you are familiar with this processing
some other context you know you can see
this is actually doing the same thing
and and we we're going to call it ou
process just for Simplicity
this is going to be a kind of a basic
building block for us to analyze
actually more complex case
okay so we have we have kind of like
understood the the quadratic and now
let's do the multi-dimensional quadratic
which is not really much different but I
think I needed
in some sense just to fall for the sake
of like future
like the the future steps so suppose you
have a multi-dimensional quadratic
yeah
supposed to have something like GX is
equals to a half times x transpose ax
where a is a matrix
in dimension d by D X is the variable in
dimension d and a is PSD
so unless suppose suppose your noise
because CT now or let's not assume it's
just a spherical gaussian let's assume
it has a covariance
Sigma
and then your update rule let's say
suppose we care about this process where
you
will descend with this
and then this becomes x t minus ETA the
gradient will just be a times x t
you add the city and this real arranging
you can I minus E to a
times x t minus ETA CT
so and you can do the same recursion
recursion as we did before right we
replace x t the definition of x t uh as
a function of x t minus 1 and you do
this recursively eventually you if you
look out you get I minus ETA a
to the power t plus 1 times x zero
minus
ETA
fine
I minus ETA a to the power k
Times Square C T minus k
and we can see this is still the same
kind of like intuition this is the
contraction of course this is the Matrix
we are multiplying something less than
one less than anything so you are
Contracting in a matrix sense and here
this is the how the noise accumulate and
also the noise
in the in the in the history in a very
far history supposed to take for example
K to be close to T right so that because
C T minus K this is something in very
very important history like in in a
remote history in a remote history the
noise becomes less important because
there's a contraction term
applied after noise is added
so
um and this is right so and you can
in some sense that so so this becomes a
more complicated formula but you can
still somewhat uh do the same thing
suppose
um
suppose if you
um
so you can still do the similar similar
calculation
if uh a and sigma
are simultaneously diagnosable
so if there are no simultaneous darkness
that diagonize it there was no likable
you can still do something to solve this
um to compute this sum to simplify the
sum that's going to be even more
competitive so let's only think about
the placement a and same thing is
diagonizable then in some sense you can
just view this as
you can just view this as viewed as
uh the different
to separate all your process in the
eigenspace
all your processes means one dimensional
problem
in the eigen
coordinate system
because when you use the eigen quarter
system then a and sigma are just both
diagonal matrices and then you are
basically just updating in uh as if you
are in One Direction
uh and in some sense form more formally
what happens is they're supposed to take
a
suppose a is u d
U transpose where D is this diagonal
matrix
um which has the eigenvalue of a let's
just suppose Sigma is u diag
Sigma I you transpose
then what you can do is that as T goes
to the infinity
the
x t roughly comes from
this gaussian which means zero because
this particle contractors and you can
look at the variance which looks like
something like this
the power K times Sigma times 1 minus
ETA
a to the power of K
uh this is just because
this is because of computer
the the variance of the right so lecture
expectation
some Matrix W could see you could see
Times Square CW transpose the covariance
of this linear transformation of
gaussian is equals to w
see transpose W transpose which is
equals W Times Sigma about transpose
right that's how you compute the
covariance of each of these terms and
negative sum of them and E A is a
symmetric Matrix so a and a transpose
are the same
so um and you can do this and then you
can simplify this when you have the
eigen decomposition so you have the
identity conversation then
I minus ETA a
is EU times diagonal
1 minus ETA e i
will transpose
and sigma is U di Sigma i u transpose
and then you can compute this
so you can compute this sum
to be something like
ETA Square Times
I guess maybe that's also Pluto let me
just do this
look at the case power you just multiply
the K in front
because the UI U transpose group got
canceled right if you of the sequence of
this
so then this becomes either Square Times
sum of
U diagonal
I guess I just assume this is the same
let's assume it's Sigma Square just to
submit it
there's a looping Sigma four times one
minus ETA
the eye
to the power 2 K U transpose
right that's this Matrix and then this
is the beauty of eigen decomposition
because everything becomes on a diagonal
and they have U score
ETA Square U times
then this becomes you take the sum
to Infinity
because I from 1 to Infinity Square
this is K
the I is for the part in the case for
the
number okay
uh Sigma I square one minus ETA d i
it's okay you transpose and this becomes
either Square Times U times something
like Sigma I Square
over d i
U transpose and there's over e top here
so let's remove each of you something
like this
so you can see that basically you have
some noise
and Noise
is something on this level so this is
the noise
level
in the eyes
eigenvector Direction
and noise level depends on the
this is this is the this is the
the
the live maybe let's just be precise
this is the
the each original noise right
iterator stochasticity
fluctuation level
because we are Computing was the
fluctuation of the each word and the
fluctuation level in the eigenvector
direction depends on the lowest level in
that direction and also depends on how
strong the contraction is the
contraction is Big then you are going to
have smaller noise smaller iterate
stochasticity
because you have so strong construction
and
um it doesn't which doesn't a lot of
noise to build up and and if the noise
is speed of course and eventually you're
gonna have like a larger Plantation it's
right
so
um and another thing that is useful to
realize is that another small remark
that is useful
is that
um
the
this Matrix
you dive
Sigma I score d i u transpose this is
always in the span
of Sigma right so
so if Sigma has some direction where
suppose Sigma is lower than capital
Sigma is lower so in some direction
there's no noise
and in those Direction the x t doesn't
have any fluctuation either
so that will be something useful for us
on in the in the future and another
thing is that
x t if you think about what's the rough
size of x t just the norm of x t this is
on auto
square root detail
because this the
this quantity is something that doesn't
depend on each other
right so if you only look at the
interdependency then the the norm of the
the stompasticity or the fluctuation in
the
in the iterate will be on all of square
root would beta and this is something
that's probably good to remember for the
moment
um uh it will be used for us in the
future as well
um any questions so far
thank you
shouldn't be opposal cylinder all right
yeah but all of those depends on
dimension for example it depends on how
large the sigma is and how large the
eyes are but in terms of dependency on
ETA
this is on order of square root B that's
what I mean
yeah
I guess I'm I'm only talking about it
depends on either so far
cool that's like the standard deviation
of
like capacity essentially
um
yeah well it's
the side effects
[Music]
so is this like for water skis
sufficiently small or yes I'm talking
about a casement she is infinity
okay so maybe maybe one way to think
about this okay I think I kind of sense
what your question is so this is the the
fluctuation in the eventual iterate
right so in the each treatment G is kind
of infinity it's different from the
noise you added at each time so actually
that's actually a very good question so
if you look at the noise that you added
at each time
so this is how large is this this is on
out of ETA if you ignore of course even
on other dependencies except ether so
each time you add some noise on all of
ETA and eventually all of this noise
build up they got added up together
and and they add up to something on out
of square roots
so so that's all the noise kind of like
accumulates but it wouldn't accumulate
to Infinity
just because because of the construction
right so because of this
this term that also constructs the noise
to some extent a little bit but still
the noise build up with one kind of like
half order higher
um in terms of ether right so it it
accumulates from ETA to e square with e
to over time
foreign
good understanding of what's coming
what's happening basically you basically
eventually it's bouncing around with the
E with the radius something like Square
will become in the in the value of this
quadratic and also you don't bounce
around in those directions where you
need to type noise
right so that's the
um
so and now let's look at the reasons
directions
so is there any way for us to map back
how like so you want to connect back to
the world where we have them in the back
screen in these networks so all
um for convex case it's not that
difficult so what you do basically what
you say is that what is sigma
Sigma is your uh so in our calculations
the sigma in our definition
a sigma is the code the code virus of
the the noise in the gradient
right you can compute towards the
covariance of noise when you use Minimax
gradients
so you can compute that and and that's
um that is something that might change
over time
but I think you can pretty much say that
when you are kind of close to Global
minimum
the changes of the covariance of the
green the the changes in the covariance
of the gradient
of the Minimax gradients is negligible
it is even higher you can basically
ignore it so basically if you want to
map this back to the mini magic with
this Sigma will just map to
the covariance of the mini batch
gradient
star
so so then you can kind of face gravity
but I don't think you got anything super
interpretable anyways so that's why I
didn't get into it
[Music]
is
yes exactly
exactly exactly that's that's exactly
correct so this is a so suppose you have
two Dimensions I think this is actually
a very good question so
so if you have One Direction which
examples
and suppose you have another Direction
[Music]
which is like this
so
the question is you know how does the
noise affect the student Nation
so and also there's a question about how
do you evaluate the effect of the noise
what's the match that you are thinking
about
so so far I'm thinking about how does
the noise change the fluctuation
in the internet right so so
so suppose I'm adding noise to the same
the same amount of noise
in both these cases I think it's indeed
true that stochastic when you said we'll
kind of like fluctuate more in this case
actually probably wouldn't look at this
it probably look like something like
if you you do some kind of like
stochastic things like this but this is
you're gonna have a larger radius
um for bouncing around and and here
you're going to have a smaller radius
you are going to be more closer to the
value however
even you have a larger radius here it
doesn't necessarily mean that you have a
larger effect and a function value
because it reflection a lot but the
function is flat as well so it's okay to
fluctuate more in some cases so I think
let's see whether
let's see whether we can compute the
fluctuations so suppose you have Sigma
Square over i d i Square this is the the
radius of the fluctuation and you
multiply
what you multiply you multiply d i
because d i is the curvature
of your open function so this is Sigma I
squared this is something that doesn't
depend on curvature e i is the curvature
right so this is the this is kind of
like x square right the the fluctuation
you have so if you look at the the fact
the effects to the function value and it
may not depend on the curvature that's
much at least not for the quadratic list
right so so
that makes sense
Okay cool so
all right so now let's talk about
non-contractive function and then this
is kind of
when the things becomes interesting but
it's interesting only on top of what we
have discussed that's why we need to
have the Walmart
so
um so non-quadratic
and so far I'm still doing
um kind of a you can still think of this
as a convex function even one
dimensional complex so far I'm going to
change that a little bit a little bit so
and again for Simplicity let's say
without loss of generality
let's assume the global minimizer
of this GX
is just the zero password right so we
still have a zero is the global
minimizer we're still doing something
around zero
and
I think I'm using a mentions notation
right now here but
I think I realized that in the Matrix
notation
oh I remember okay so the reason why I'm
using dimensions for patients because
now I don't have to do the two things
the scalar case in the major Escape but
but you can in your mind you can pretty
much interpret all business scalars
um
um Okay so
so I'm also assuming that because zero
is going to mean that means that the
gradient at zero is zero
right that's a necessary condition and
also that means that the hyacin
and g0 is PSD
okay
so
and let's also assume
This is the part when they kind of like
become not super super reverse but that
we can make this far Universe it's just
that I wouldn't have
time to uh to do all the river stuff but
this part is doable so suppose you will
assume each rate are closed
to zero so start from somewhere that's
close to zero expansion
around zero
so so what you do is you do x t plus one
is equal to x t that's ETA times going
into
at x t plus cos c t
and into 10 expansion
to approximate the gradient
at at the city at x t
so how to do a third expansion
so if you take advantage zero you would
even got you're gonna get the number so
you zero
plus now plus Square G 0 times x
T minus zero
and plus you know
block Cube G zero
at x t x t
and maybe let's have also High all the
terms
which we are going to ignore
heuristically and then
I'm gonna get episode
T sometimes
so I guess you know if you
if you're not familiar with the note
Matrix thing then I guess this is really
just saying that g
G Prime x t is roughly equals to G Prime
zero times x t plus G prime prime zero
times x t squared
plus GQ
third order derivative terms
wait what I'm doing here so
this there's no x t here there's x t
times x t square plus even high order
terms
sometimes right so but homologous
rotation that this
if you do the Matrix thing that this is
the Matrix Vector product
and this is a tensor Vector product let
me explain that a little bit so
so image so if you do the market
dimensional case this is a third of the
tensor
d by B by D so and suppose you have a t
that is a third or a tensor
then I'm using this t
t
X
y
reacts and Y are all vectors is defined
to be
a vector so suppose so this is a this is
the multiplication of this tensor with
two vectors it's first of all is a
vector
and second the definition of this is
that
the ith coordinate of this is
the sum over j k t i j k x i y j so x x
k y
x j
y k so basically sum over
the remaining Point J and K and you
leave the I along the left and that's
the
outcome
so this is the basically the scalar
expansion in multiple dimensions
Okay so
by the way just a reminder for the scrap
note takers I think for this kind of
small things I write on the side you
please also take notes for those because
they are useful for
um for readers as well if someone
doesn't have time to take the lectures
they would like to know so I think these
small explanations are also useful
um you can just have a small kind of
remark of some run it in a paragraph
so
um
all right so first of that I have a
third expansion and then we can see that
so while we so so we're expecting
something somewhat similar to what we
have done before right so and and indeed
you will see that because a
this is gonna be zero because this is
the gradient at zero
and this is zero so and so basically
what we're gonna get is that
x t minus ETA
times
okay so I guess
let me Define
as for Simplicity H to be has used
like H to be the hessing and zero
then this you can rewrite this as x t
minus beta h x t
minus beta
uh cos CT
and minus the third the third order
I guess I'm also going to Define
let me see what's my location here
I Define t to be
the third order derivative
and then this is T
x t x t
so and how terms Let's ignore that from
from now on either way we are not going
to really formulating
we just have an approximation here so
and then this is I minus ETA h
x t
minus ETA cos c t
minus ETA t
x t x t
and I think you can see I guess what I
was hoping for you to see is that
the third law term is something new but
the first alternate second order are not
new a noise term and this is the second
order are exactly what we had before
right so if you look look at
here
so for
the quadratic case
you have extraction and you have a noise
the extraction is linear and you have
the noise and now the only difference is
that you see you have additional term
from the third order derivative and
that's expected because if you don't
have the third order you ignore the
third order term it becomes just
quadratic so that's why we want to
explain how to the third order because
we want to really use the fact that this
is not a quadratic function
so basically you can think of this as
two process going on right so one
process is this this
OU process kind of like this kind of
like basic one about quadratic and you
have additional term that's kind of like
make it a little bit more conflict
right so and how do you proceed here
so
if you really think about um
thank you
so so in some sense if you so there is
one thing okay so this is okayuristic
of course like uh your wishes
so in certain cases you can you're kind
of attempting to even drop the third
long term because that may be a small
term and let's try to do that right so
this is
so just to drop the third order
foreign
[Music]
then you have this process X is updated
by
something like this
right so this is the process this is
something we have finalized and we know
that when convergence
x t will be something on the order
from each other so here
I'm ignoring all the dependencies
accepted that penicillin ETA
so and
and now if you look at you look back on
uh what happened with this tunnel term
so when X is on this order
so each of t x t x t what is this this
is on order of ETA Square because x t
contributes square root ETA this
actually contributes for reader and
there's an ETA here so basically you
have e to the square term
um which sounds very small
why this is very small this is much
smaller this is so each square is
much much smaller than for example ETA
City
right but that probably is not unfair
because Cassidy is doing some random
stuff so uh but ether square is also
much much smaller than even just e to H
x t which is on order of either
uh 1.5
so basically the changes
of your process where the two other
changes of your process is these two
terms
right and this term you can say
comparing with that is a little kind of
like a
uh uh unfair because that term is doing
some random stuff right so maybe you
shouldn't compare with the absolute
value of x just because eventually they
will subtract there will be some
cancellation but at least you compare
with the the other deterministic term e
to hxt
you are still uh this is a square term
is still much smaller
than a deterministic term so in some
sense it's very tempting to say that
okay this this final term is t x t x t
thing
is uh it's very it's very small
right so so the conclusion would be that
you know uh um
the conclusion is that this is kind of
negligible
so and indeed it's true when so and this
is indeed true this is negligible and
and you need these two under one
condition when the age
the housing is strictly PSD
so so that's why that that's when you
have Construction in all different
directions
so
so however when H is not strictly PSD so
for example in some Direction
so basically in other words if you think
about this so
this term is only on out of ETA to the
1.5 when H is not zero right so if H is
zero in some direction then this ETA H
calc C term is just literally zero so
then the ETA Square term is running
right so so basically if in
in some Direction
where
H is zero
then ETA h x t is just a zero in that
direction
and then
ETA Square becomes the largest
largest update
together
city is always the largest if you really
look at the absolute value right so if
the city is a lot of what this is on out
of just the Ethan it's always the
largest but I think I I kind of I try to
I'm trying to argue that in the city if
you compare with that it's a little bit
kind of like
um
is leading in the sense that if a city
is doing random stuff right so in one
step is to it's going to pause the
direction the other step is going to
negative Direction So eventually So
eventually the the so basically what
happens is that if I have a random
sarcastic term suppose you have a
sarcastic term
or mean zero term
such that if you have one stack
is on out of ETA implies
uh eventually like matches the
this will be something like on the
square root either
that's kind of like what we have
discussed in the quadratic history if
every step is stochastic can give you a
return
noise perturbation and then eventually
they will build up to square root data
so uh however when you have a
deterministic term
so if one step
is something like ETA then eventually
it's unclear what you will go down it
probably would build up to either T
because it
times Little T let's say
it it won't kind of like they won't
cancel maybe this is a little bit I'm
not sure about this is the best way to
explain it
um
how do I say this so either way this is
all the heuristic or because you know it
requires a little bit more if you want
to format all of let's say it requires a
little more work but I guess what I'm
maybe let me delete what I'm saying is
basically like the
the low the low quality the largest
update but like in our case by locally
the audience out there of course is
either casinos but this one will have
cancellation over time
because in future you're gonna have like
a you you can move in different
directions so because that's why it's
probably good to also compare with the
deterministic changes which is the ETA
htxt
and we compare with that typically the
domestic changes is bigger than the ETA
Square term from the third hour
derivative
um but when when H is zero in some
direction there is no longer true
so
um so so so but but you can so so you
sometimes you can prove that if H is
um
so if when so when H is strictly
positive no zero then it's negligible
and otherwise becomes a becomes tricky
right so if H has a
completely flat Direction it becomes a
tree
so I think here is a good point maybe
let's just continue with this so when
this is case then uh so the third so in
this case the third order
[Music]
will
introduce some biases but very small
some buys but very small
and small in a sense as ETA goes to zero
this becomes new becomes negligible and
I think I have some kind of like a
um
figures here
yes so I have this figure
so I'm just see whether you can see it
yes so
this is a little bit small I guess maybe
this way
so the function
is a one-dimensional function it's a
convex one so I'm in the case where the
the H is strictly bigger than 0. so the
h
because it's one dimension this is
strictly you know convex function so so
so this is the function but it's not
like a quadratic it's something like a I
think it's quadratically on both sides
but it's not the same kind of curvature
the left hand side is more flat and the
right hand side is more Sharp
and
um
and if you the green descent
so I guess probably the only thing
important is this so if you look at this
is after you take
results
and you can see that the mean
like the iterate is bouncing around
right between this is the this is the
each this is the distribution of each
rate
distribution of the XT when T is
10 24.
so 1094 is pretty big considered to be
infinitive right so and you can see that
it's bouncing around around zero zero is
the global minimum but
the the mean is no longer zero anymore
because you have the third order kind of
like derivative and the mean is
something left
um
to zero
um in some sense you prefer the left
hand side a little more than the right
hand side because it's easy to stay on
the left hand side the left hand side is
lighter so it's easier to stay there
because the construction is weaker
and the right hand side you know it's
sharper and it's you add some noise and
you kind of like contract it and you go
back to the to zero quickly more quickly
so that's why the the the the buyers is
towards the left hand side where you
have flighter curvature but the bias is
relatively small you can see right like
uh you can even say this is negligible
because the bot at least you know if you
if you do take a random Point you're
going to take something between minus
0.05 to 0.05 maybe and the bias is only
a very very small number I know but you
you are like you're stuck your
fluctuation is bigger than the bias for
sure
so so that's why in the classical kind
of like uh
um in a classical kind of like
um like optimization settings people
didn't really pay too much attention to
this I think they are
they are uh some papers I guess uh
so I guess there's this paper by
e
17. bridging
the Gap I guess between
constant
step size SUV
and the market option so this paper
characterize this
effect for convex case
and you can see from the top title of
this paper right it's talking about
constant step sets and why you have to
talk about constant steps that just
because this will go
if you Decay the step size then this
bias effect will be even smaller and it
will be negligible just completely gone
right eventually so that's why you have
to to make this even somewhat useful you
know someone can make a difference you
have to make the steps that's not going
to zero so that's why in the convex case
people think we don't care about this
that much in some other cases you know
you care about this a little bit this
figure is from one of my recent paper
um with some
um
students as an effort all right guys so
and here the reason why we try about
this is because you have um you have
multiple machines and for some other
reasons you have to care about this but
technically you wouldn't really care
that much about it
um
uh just because the buy is small
okay so now let's go back to
uh now let's move on to
um
okay finally we are moving to the
implicit regulation effect
so the more more complex case
I'm heading too fast this could
through it I guess
who's stronger
thank you
press it right
so
um so and these are cases where both
age and
Sigma
are not
for Rock
so your hazard and your noise are both
somewhat
not for full dimensional and this is now
something to be super surprised this is
called party comes from
comes from
over parametrization
especially I think it's easier to think
about the same the housing if you have a
manifold of global minimum
then along that direction of the
manifold your housing will be zero
so so as long as you have a lot of
different Global minimum then your high
system will be flat is will be zero in
certain directions
so
um and let's say suppose
so possibly let me not discuss when this
can happen exactly because you need some
calculations uh so forth but suppose
let's say Asian Sigma are both
in some Subspace in a Subspace
K and the Subspace K is low dimensional
or this is not full dimensional
and
um and if the loss is quadratic
for the moment just let's still think
about the laws it's quadratic I guess we
have computers
we said that
the iterate will have zero something
like this
recall that this is our calculation
Sigma Square D I
U transpose
and so my kind of the picture I think is
that
uh
but
um
there's no
so so basically you have no noise
and no construction
nothing
in the in the in the property the
perpendicular space of height so in some
sense I think the function
look like this in when you have so
suppose you have
some direction of
K this is the direction of K
then this is the direction of
k-park
and and suppose your function is
quadratic in dimension of K
something like this I'm not sure whether
you can
think of my drawing is too bad so
so imagine how variety this is a I'm
drawing a violin like this
and but this value is completely kind of
like oblivious to Dimension paper
so and so so this thing
is the middle of the Violet this is the
three dividing so so basically then what
happens is that if you start somewhere
here
everything happens in the direction of K
and nothing happens Direction paper so
you're basically bouncing along the
direction of K so basically you maybe go
here here and go about to do some
bouncing like something like this but
you never move in the direction of paper
so in Caper it's kind of like a you just
know nothing you know nothing or you
don't move at all
so that's still not kind of liking that
that's that's a little bit impressive
bias we implicit requisition because
the implicit requisition comes from what
comes from the transition if you start
with this point then you're gonna
stay in this uh in this in this part but
if you start here then you will bounce
around here
right and this is exactly what happens
when you have over parameters linear
model because we have all preciously
anymore you never leave the Subspace
it may never lead to some Subspace any
any other substitution never moved so
but this is not the most important thing
right so about the noise but because the
noise doesn't really do much it's really
just that you cannot leave a certain
certain substance however when your loss
is quadratic when your loss is not
quadratic then
the third dollar term is is going to
measure
so this is the the main thing I want to
kind of like
Conway today but unfortunately just
because this is complicated so I
probably wouldn't be able to do all the
everything rigorously
so I just really can't do everything
regressing so what happens is that
if you the loss is not quadratic the
recall that what happens is you have x t
plus one is equal to one minus E to H
minus ETA t x t
x t
plus High auditor
and this is happening
so this
is
working
[Music]
in K because the I assume that H is
working hey and the noise is always in
pain in the Subspace so this main part
is we're always working hey your boss
are running head and and this is working
in paper
and that's that makes them kind of
completely separate so there's nothing
you can control the the sort of term the
third term can build up
for long and long a very long time
so
um so maybe this is the one let me see
so basically let's see so
I probably will go to this figure
multiple times
right so this is what's happening here
so
I don't think I can
I don't think I can draw anything here
so but the
maybe maybe you first watch it and then
I'm going to go to a static figure so
that you can
uh I can I can annotate
so this is a sarcastic we've been inside
on this on this in this Valley
then you can see that it's moving in
this Valley so now let's look at the
static figure I think I have one
somewhere
thank you
so
in our life you know the mathematical
language so this direction
let's see a different color
so this is the direction of the k
perk
and this is the direction
of K so this direction is K
okay and so but here this is not a
quadratic because it's at least this is
another project because you're at least
the the K perfect direction does measure
to some extent
because the paper you can see that from
if you go from here to here you're going
to go to flightcher and flighter region
right so
what happens is that most of your work
is in the K Direction you are just
bouncing around in K Direction
but there is some several term that
drives you in the paper Direction and
that can build up eventually for a long
time right recall that you start from
here you do a lot of like bouncing
around but eventually after you bounce
for so long time you move in the paper
Direction and this is just because the
third hour term is
is accumulating for long for a long time
until you go to The Brighter region
so um so the so the main term is doing
the bouncing and the the lower term is
doing is accumulating in the you know in
the direction of the violate
um
any questions so far I can go I'll go
back to this bigger problem once again
just one second with a little bit more
math
[Music]
yeah that's a that's a great question so
so if you know this is what's happening
why not just do something more expensive
to make it faster right so
um
I think there are several let me see so
there are several things that you know
like this is um this is a good question
but this is not something super new like
people have thought about it and I have
thought about it I think there are
multiple
constraints we have to
um kind of respect like uh you know I
still think this is a feasible thing
direction to go but it's not easy so and
and I don't think there is a um there's
existing paper that can really achieve
this very well so so one of the thing is
that so how do you go to the valley
so
um so how do you go to the value I think
that's that's not too hard because you
have to use
but not tribute because to go to the
value you have to
either Decay already rate or make your
back size bigger so that you have a
smaller noise
but that requires putting more compute
because you want to be more accurate so
that you but sometimes you want to be
more accurate in the Creator so if you
require small countries
so so that's one small segment so
whether you you really can afford those
compute to really go to the body in the
first place I think you can probably in
most cases you can
um but it's not like a for free so you
do have to consider the cost
so and then you go to the valley and
then you do the you do this right you
move in okay
but the problem becomes that the real
picture is not just one single
it's actually this is only a local View
so once you go to here maybe
you know if locally it sounds great but
I'm going to a better place but maybe
there's actually this function has a lot
of other parts so actually I have to
travel really far far away somewhere
else so then you have to do this again
this local view again and then try to do
it and so and so forth right so then it
becomes a then you have to also find a
new value and then probably find the
direction of the paper and also find the
direction of paper it's also not
matching because it requires completing
the third hour derivative
uh computer serial derivative
on one example is still okay
it costs you
completing any other derivative on one
example takes you a constant Factor more
than completing the personal derivative
this is a very interesting thing about
deep learning so
Computing the only derivative is give
you almost your price almost the same
time as as completing the first
derivative I start your automation
vector so but but I do you don't have to
pay a constant bucket sometimes two or
three times more on computers and and
also you have to do this for
um
um and this team this K-pop Direction so
do to to get it
to get it uh um exactly you also have to
do a full batch full
derivative of the of the full function
of the of the population of the other
population of the of the full empirical
function so if you use the Smith
investing then maybe you wouldn't get
the K from Direction very accurately
so so there's a bunch of decisions which
makes it complicated you know we don't
even know exactly which one is the
bottleneck so it's a little bit tricky
so but that's a great question yeah so
we will try very hard to just somehow do
this like for quite a while already yeah
so
um okay all right so now let's see so
I think I'll do a little more math just
to kind of give you a small feeling
about how how we perceive to Analyze
This so and the way to analyze this is
that you somehow view this as I said as
a two things so you first Define a
companion process which is easier to
Define
unity plus one to be one minus E to H
U T minus E capacity
and this is what others do
because this is space where you are
doing optimization on the quadratic
approximation
and we have done this already
so and and then you characterize the
difference between them so x t minus u t
we Define this to be RT so basically the
main question is that what is what RT is
doing
and we're going to take a take a uh we
can compute the recursor recursion of RT
right this is equals to you plug in the
definition of x t plus one and U plus
one you go to one minus E2
h x t minus u t
minus E so t x t x t
plus high order term
and then still and then it's 1 minus ETA
h r t plus ETA t
x t x t
and and the interesting theory is that
you still have the construction
and this is the bias or the
regularization effect but there's no
noise anymore there's no fantasticity
no stochasticity
you know there's still a lot of
stochastic in rxt but when you at least
you don't have the CT term that you have
added intentionally
just because this is you are taking a
div with the with the sarcastic reaction
so and you can actually remove the XT as
well because you can basically claim
that this is close to
the version where you plug in
it will plug in actually you plug in ut
this is just because
um this is just because
XT and UT
are somewhat similar of course you want
to understand the exact difference but
for this level especially because you
are multiplier ETA here
so like the the further differences
becomes even higher the term you can
jump because you can jump
so
now what happens is that if you look at
the the the the div
if you look at the in the Subspace the
Subspace
of K right which is the the span of H
this is still a contraction
because you have some additional biases
but the biases will be corrected by the
construction eventually
so however for
um for the for the inner Caper Subspace
the construction is gone
people you project everything to the
main purpose of space
then you got
right so the the age doesn't have any
effect anymore because age has nothing
to do with the K curve Direction you
just project it out
so now the the thing is really simple so
in the K-pop Subspace you are just
basically taking the previous
RT projecting a character from space
plus something new so basically you are
just the adding up
you don't have any construction even so
if you do this in a recursively you are
going to get
the K-pop of r0 minus the sum
of
so now it becomes you know the question
becomes how do you understand the sum of
the external term and by the way I've
never told you where the third dollar
term is going right I only claim that
there is a third dollar term I didn't
really say where it's going so now it's
the question is what the third other
term terms are going in average right so
in the long run over time
so we can kind of ignore this this is
just a restriction to the sub Subspace
so if you look at the sum of the where
the third order is going
so this you can
um
so so first of all let's assume maybe
this is a heuristic let's say it's a
system Duty
um
let's say
as is something like UK
UK transport is the covalent of UK
uh this is the SK goes to Infinity
and also assume
is okay or mixes as a market option I'm
not sure whether you are familiar with
this Max from gym mixing but you just
assume that UK is kind of like doing the
boss right you is that doing the
bouncing around
you assume that it's really just doing
that it's kind of like a gaussian then
an ice is the covalents of the gaussian
and then this one
you can rewrite this as you know
uh T of
in some sense this is like
it goes to loyalty times roughly because
Little T times
that she was the expectation for you
the UK transport or maybe with us
so I guess maybe
so what I'm doing here is that suppose
you have some variable U that is drawn
from us
from gaussian Luis
converts as the
the expectation of T EU
is equals to T of
this is
expectation
okay let's look at the ice coordinate
then this is sum of J
t i j k u j u k and you can export it
sorry guys okay to this
and then you switch the sum with the
expectation you have j k t i j k
expectation UJ
you okay
and this is sum over j k t i j k
expectation uu transpose we take the JK
coordinate
and this is you know if you know this by
T of
expectation uu transpose
so so you can also apply the tensor on a
matrix and the definition is really just
this
so the definition of t applied on The
Matrix is
that you have some
of t i j k
thanks Jake
all right so I think this might be a
little bit too
too much for this course but another way
you can basically at the end of the day
what you have is that you build
I guess there's a detail here of my body
so this t comes from you have multiple
times right you have three steps that's
where you got T and ETA is what you got
from this ETA and this is something like
you apply the tensor to the average
covariance the mixed state the mixed
covers uh thing so basically the
question becomes like what is X
if you don't ask then you know which
direction you're going and and you know
how far you're going you are going by T
times this this direction because you
have Takes Two Steps so
so the next to the so the final question
is that what this TS is and this is very
informal and not even exactly correct
um I need to fix it you need something
um a little more
um your operations so so this various
Direction T of s right minus two of us
is the biased Direction
so this last direction is equals to
minus I guess remember what's the t t is
the first derivative and S is the
iterate of the you know ice is just a
matrix for a moment and you can rewrite
this
so if you think about what is this
this is the gradient of
the inner Paradox of the hessing
times x
so right this is the equation
and in some sense you can argue that
this is a
heuristic argument and actually it's not
even a correct I've not even 100 correct
argument
so the tias is
trying to make
novela Square GX times s
smaller because you are moving
radiant of that function right so let's
define this to be RX
right so you're moving the negative RX
in that negative number RX Direction
that's why you can argue that you are
trying to make that function smaller
so this node bias is trying to make
is this minus TS term is trying to
make the RX smaller by moving in the
gradient of this RX Direction
so and eventually I think that if you
work out all of this kind of like
um some of details right so with a lot
of other
uh like uh
like a stance and fixes and assumptions
you know
and I think I'm not going to go through
all of this it's we're already going to
granulate
um but you can somewhat's prove in
certain cases
let me just write down what finally you
can prove
so can prove
something like
actually
with
the so-called label noise
I I didn't tell you what label noise
mean
um it doesn't matter it's the one kind
of noise it's not exactly
which is some additional noise and
convert this to
a stationary point
of
the regularized loss
IO plus Lambda r i o h plus MDA R where
power Theta is equals to roughly equals
to
trees
of the hyacin
of the loss
so yeah so I guess
there's no need to understand any
details here in this there are some
other subjects there are other
assumptions so and so forth I just want
to give you a taste on what kind of
theorems you may hope to prove
so and so basically you are saying like
if you write CD
okay this is on the original loss on our
heart so if you run a certain kind of
STD on the unrecognized loss
it will convert this to the stationary
point of a regular source
so that's why you get this regularizer
for free
and what regularizer tells us that here
the radicalizer is the trace of the
housing is something about the flatness
the flatness of the Lost Arrowhead right
the housing is the curvature the trace
of Tyson is about the flatness at that
point so so you are increasingly
encouraging the flatness
um of the
um
of the loss function
so but this has a a lot of things hidden
here and actually I think I'm missing a
few kind of important questions
important assumptions you know I'm not
writing down some of the important
assumptions just because they are not
um you know it takes too much time to
write out but this is kind of like
something we may hope to improve under
some cases
okay any questions
as well
that's a great point so the so the
question just to rephrase the question
is the question is that whether the even
high order derivative the fourth order
gradient would increase the Infuse the
Box
um I think on the conceptual level if
your third order uh thing is not zero
then I think the fourth dollar one
wouldn't matter that much and if the
federal return is zero I think indeed uh
there should be upon other just if the
four dollar term would have effect
um but so far we're not we're not
thinking about the well we are assuming
the the third order is doing something
so so that's all our time will be done
with another third launcher
support yourself
the in The Last Theorem the stationary
launch is because
it's okay
oh I think yeah so the question is why
the regularization is the trace of
testing this is because
when the recordizer is about a signal
term the second derivative
then the direction you want to move to
is the gradient of the regulator
but because you so when you have a
recognizer what do you really mean it
means that you should move to the
direction of the period of direct life
that's why
that's how they they match up so so
actually the direction really moved to
is the third hour derivative depends on
the third level derivative of the last
one
so so I guess there are two views one
view is that you you look at the
on the on the regulator on level then
it's the subs currently it's the second
order term the second order derivative
of the most
and another view is that you cut the
uh the actual the each space the current
is the third order derivative it's about
third of the derivative of the loss and
suppose in the in the iterate space the
standard derivative manages
then you have to talk about the fourth
order
and in that case the regularizer
probably will be about a third another
derivative of the of the loss it's
because your records is always one order
up compared to the direction of the
movement
does that make some sense
um
medication
yeah so so why flight station point is
better right so I think
yeah why whether it's better or not so
um I think I'm going to talk about that
immediately next in the next beginning
of the next action
the answer is that we do believe is is
generally better
um it depends on some it's kind of um
relates to the limitlessness of the
models but I'll discuss more excellent
on on Wednesday
expect